huh finally back from Comic Con my gosh
I wrote on my Twitter that I felt like
Vegeta during the frieza saga ah but
I've gotten some rest and I can finally
tell you guys my thoughts on the Batman
V Superman trailer that premiered in
Hall H at Comic Con I wasn't cool enough
to be there I didn't get in but thank
goodness it was officially released
online directly after that so I got to
watch it and I can tell you I'm pretty
excited for this movie but that's not
really that surprising of a thing to say
it's Batman V Superman when I grew up
Superman was like the greatest thing in
the world and Batman was even better
these are two of my childhood favorite
iconic people and we get to see them go
head-to-head is it going deeper is it
going beyond is it reaching for anything
other than explosions and fistfights it
looks like it is one of the things I
really like about this trailer is it
shows Superman on trial they show a
protest going on calling Superman an
alien from another world people aren't
excited about Superman anymore there are
people who need saved some people who
view him as this god-like figure are
people who love him and people who hate
him usually in superhero movies it's
kind of one-sided either everyone hates
this guy for a while because the Dark
Knight did this or because spider-man
did this or everyone loves him I like
how this movie actually has two opposing
sides we have some love and some hate
it's not just one but let's talk about
what most of us are excited to see and
that is Batman this might be my favorite
Batman costume ever in a movie it is so
so iconic looking it is a perfect
recreation of Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns Batman costume I'm loving the
look of Ben Affleck as Bruce Wayne I
said it from the beginning guys he is
gonna rock it as this character and he
really looks like he's going to bring it
and a thing that I like most about this
trailer is that it addresses a big thing
that people were up in arms about in the
first Man of Steel movie and that was
the destruction that Superman and Zod
caused in Metropolis is he causing more
good or bad in the city because of his
presence in the previous Man of Steel we
saw Superman and Zod fire beaming each
other in that building this trailer puts
you from the perspective of Bruce Wayne
on the streets looking up seeing this
building explode and tumbled down on
innocent bystanders we see batfleck
running into that cloud
trying to rescue this little girl the
perspective of someone on the ground
during that event says so much about
what these writers are going for with
this movie they are taking flaws with
the first film using them to make the
second one better that is such a great
idea and I'm so excited about the
writing for this movie I really hope the
dialogue is as good as some of these
story ideas let's talk about a major
issue with this trailer that I have
though and my wife commented on it when
she saw it - it looks a bit bloated a
really big danger with these superhero
films is having so many characters we
have Wonder Woman for the first time
ever in a movie that's awesome we see a
few shots of her and they look
incredible she really looks great as
Wonder Woman but we also have lex luthor
played by jesse eisenberg which to this
day is still my biggest fear there's a
lot of stuff going on in this movie
there's a romance between amy adams and
henry cavill we have Superman's mom we
have Perry White there are so many
characters in this movie and there's a
huge danger of this movie becoming too
big for its own good and we haven't even
talked yet about the possibilities of
Aquaman or whoever else might show up I
just really hope the writers locked down
this screenplay - what we really need to
see a compelling story the core elements
we really want to see and that is the
psychological battle and the physical
battle that goes on between Batman and
Superman that's what we're paying to see
and I hope the movie doesn't get too
bloated because I'm still on the fence
about Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor in
regards to Easter eggs in this trailer I
love the fact that they show Robins old
costume that Batman is keeping in his
Batcave and you see the Joker has
spray-painted something on him hinting
at that death in the family arc in which
the Joker killed Robin that is awesome
that is so cool as a fan of Batman and
Superman that made me this tingling will
it affect the story
who knows it's just a cool Easter egg
you know it's something cool for Comic
Con fans to get excited about also
there's a shot in this trailer that is
directly tributing one of the covers
from Frank Miller and I love it it's
beautiful
we finally get a look at Jeremy Irons as
Alfred fantastic casting I can't wait to
see how he portrays this character
Michael Caine's pretty freaking perfect
though so he's got some big shoes to
fill and there's this weird sequence in
which Superman's soldiers are fighting
Batman and Batman is dressed in like a
coat and some
goggles I have no idea what that is
there's also a shot in this trailer of
general Zod's body being unzipped from a
body bag so something is going on there
who knows but the ending of this trailer
is the definition of epic when Superman
rips open the Batmobile and Batman
stands up like you son of a bitch it's
on now guys you know I'm excited for
this movie it's a stupid thing for me to
say that it's obvious I'm excited for it
most of you are too
let's hope it's as good as it can be
what are your guys thoughts on this
trailer let me know below and I also
want to say I had such a great time at
Comic Con I got to meet so many people
so many of you guys it was overwhelming
I almost like I was like oh my gosh this
is awesome these people are incredible
you guys are incredible I got to meet so
many people I had such a great time and
if you want to see the two panels that I
went on they're online now the Masters
of the web panel hosted by John Campea
that link is below we talked all about
our perception of the internet movies
were excited about we take audience
questions it was tons of fun and the
live movie fights with screen junkies in
which we all basically had a WWE match
of shouting insults and just being
children and having a great time and it
was so cool meeting you guys I hope you
guys check out both of those panels
below and also recognize that we're just
having fun we don't actually hate each
other we all partied all weekend we
hugged each other Nick Monday kissed me
on the face literally kissed me on the
face so yeah it was awesome we had a
great time guys I hope you guys enjoy
those panels if you weren't able to be
there yourself
and as always thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes
[Applause]
[Music]